chaque jour des millions de gens se
croisent dans le métro ce monde
souterrain s'étend comme une réplique du
monde du dessus avec ses lois et ses
transgressions ses refuges et ses
angoisses et une obsession de tous les
instants le temps
et bien voilà on va arriver à commerce
sur la ligne 8
ça fait 23 ans que moi je conduis les
métros sur cette ligne
la plus belle ligne du réseau enfin je
sais pas c'est la plus belle mais en
tout cas c'est la plus longue
elle fait 27 km environ et
il nous faut deux heures pour faire
l'aller-retour
c'est
samedi prestige en entreprise quand même
on est on est fier d'être conducteurs de
métro on est on est attaché à notre
bécane vous savez bon comme moi ou même
un titre qui conduit le métro depuis 8
ou 10 ans sur le numéro 8
par cœur
on appelle ça des courbes mais en fait
ça du virage il connaît chaque côte nous
on appelle ça des rampe il connaît
chaque signal
dans le métro toutes nos vitesses sont
inscrites sur bande elles sont épluchées
le soir
par des professionnels
on appelle des vendeurs puisqu'ils
et donc
interdiction
de dépasser les vitesses aucune
tolérance
ah il y a pas grand monde aujourd'hui
des fois Bastille les caisses en noires
de monde comme la République alors
évidemment quand les caisses sont
lourdement comme ça on a toujours peur
on a toujours peur quelqu'un de français
faut pas ou n'importe quoi
c'est qu'on les aime bien le petit
voyageur on devrait pas que qu'il arrive
un accident avec un peu la voix
vous voyez le gros avantage de la numéro
8 c'est que on voit un petit peu le
soleil
on voit le temps qu'il fait et
aujourd'hui il fait très très beau c'est
sympa
la plupart de mes collègues
malheureusement ils ont pas de partir
aérienne comme ça alors comment ils font
pour savoir le temps qu'il fait
il regarde il regarde les toilettes des
femmes
quand elles sont habillés courtes c'est
qu'il fait beau
ouais
c'est qu'il pleut
et quand elles sont habillées chaudement
c'est qu'il fait froid si tu rêves
quand la vie est malade viens je
t'emmène dans le métro
donne nation à Nanterre au centre de la
Terre viens je t'emmène dans le métro
merci
Jean-Michel voulais m'aimer ce métier de
conducteur de métro ouais j'aime bien
ouais j'aime bien qu'est-ce que vous
aimez
ce que j'aime
on est seul dans la cabine et moi ça me
convient bien que bon j'aime bien aussi
vous savez des fois on souffre la
solitude quand même quand on est seul on
aime bien avoir un peu de compagnie
comme ça mais c'est un métier c'est un
peu paradoxal parce que bon la RATP
c'est c'est une administration tout ça
mais je sais pas j'ai vraiment
l'impression d'être mon capitaine sur le
bateau
personne personne pour m'embêter je suis
mon propre chef
qui travaillait dans le métro
la famille
ma cousine mon nom
et oui attendez je cherche si j'ai un
cousin si deux cousins tu sais de la
famille RATP mais pas ma famille proche
ni mon père lui-même et mon frère mon
frère
il est plus jeune et plus âgé
on a demandé à Guilaine de nous
rejoindre Guilaine ça fait vous un an
que vous êtes à la RATP vous êtes en
même temps agent de station et
contrôleuse disons que je suis agent de
station et je suis un peu à faire du
contrôle de temps en temps ça fait
partie aussi de mon métier pourquoi vous
avez envie de d'entrer à la RATP disons
que moi juste une petite provinciale
déjà et c'est vrai que bon déjà Paris la
capitale ça tient beaucoup les
c'est pour nous c'est un mythe un peu
c'est la ville c'est la capitale et la
RATP
tout du moins les transports font partie
de la vie de la capitale justement et on
est souvent confrontés à des choses qui
se passeraient pas forcément en dehors
de Paris
dire que c'est vraiment un mode de vie
complètement différent
si tout était rose en haut je pense que
ce serait moins noir des fois dans le
métro quoi
les passagers la plupart du temps ça se
passe plutôt bien
je n'ai pas encore eu de problème de mon
travail au niveau du contrôle jamais
vous avez eu en revanche des problèmes
il y a très peu de temps c'est un
problème qui aurait pu m'arriver
n'importe où
mais quelque chose de très méchant c'est
à l'ouverture d'une station voilà
c'était très tôt le matin et voilà
j'avais encore gardé des marques
donc
qui se voient mais parce que logiquement
je crois que j'arrive à surmonter la
chose n'avait pas eu envie d'arrêter
absolument pas absolument pas je crois
que ça a pire des choses de rester
inactif est-ce que vous aviez pensé
qu'effectivement
jamais la moindre agression pour moi
pour moi vous comprenez rien
qui arrive
toute la ligne toute la ligne de sec
quand il y a un suicide tout de suite on
s'intéresse on s'est dit mais qui c'est
qui a eu qui c'est qui le suicide ça va
de Balard c'est un lot de Julia ça va de
Créteil et tout de suite oui on veut
savoir il y a une prise en charge
aujourd'hui non au niveau de la RATP
a des problèmes
il a un psychologue
ce qu'il peut aussi se produire des
choses drôles ici dans le métro
si un jour 9
et le dimanche je vais regarder Jacques
Martin la télévision là qui qui nous
prenait la tête en ce temps là avec sa
pêche aux moules toute façon j'ai une
chanson que José et je sais pas pourquoi
le lundi matin je me suis mis à la
chanter comme ça dans ma cabine c'était
pas vraiment merci pourtant
dans ma tête et j'ai chanté et mon micro
avec lequel je pars au voyageur était il
était resté coincé coincé ce qui fait
que bon les les cinq voitures profiter
de ma chanson et là et la station
bonne pêche monsieur je me suis mis à
bière rougir
un groupe un groupe de musique service
public j'ai consacré ma vie à la musique
en parallèle quoi en parallèle de mon de
mon travail et voilà c'est un choix que
j'ai fait et je crois que j'ai fait le
bon choix
et chante
moi je savais pas du tout qu'il était
arrivé sur le numéro 8 ben à Créteil et
ce sont ce sont mes chefs quoi mes chefs
qui m'ont téléphoné un jour en me disant
c'est une des chanteuses qui est mer qui
chante très très bien il faut que tu il
faut que tu l'auditionnes qu'elle rentre
dans ton groupe et donc elle convenait
tout à fait et puis elle est devenue
maintenant quelqu'un de d'incontournable
dans le groupe si je vous demande
d'interpréter comme ça capella une
chanson tous les deux vous le faites ici
vous êtes capable de notre répertoire
bienvenu un ingénieur breton qui a
inventé le métro parisien
c'est prête
Paris est dans l'urgence car pour
l'exposition ça vient d'être décidé on
fait le métro mais en l'air ou sous la
terre où circulera-t-on les rois de la
plancha dessin se creuse est désormais
[Musique]
omnibus et diligence
à Paris le manche l'inconnu
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]